hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember if monkeys aren't funny so why
do we keep using them well I guess it's
because they're so easy to Train and to
their credit they're the only animal
that can come close to doing some real
acting but a monkey needs to look sad
pick it looks at what a monkey needs to
look happy it can look happy when a
monkey needs to piss you off it makes
Dunston checks in for 1996 these were
old tired uninventive jokes some person
falls in something the monkey smiles and
somebody shrugs I wouldn't show that to
a dying child who could only be saved by
watching a movie but Dustin checks in is
the only movie around because the other
movies were destroyed by this one being
so bad yet somehow it can provide the
cure for this very odd disease see
sucking the funny out of me let's get
this over with we start off with a man
entering a hotel played by Glenn Jetix
we then see a little kid named Kyle
watching from afar you should see this
lady injecting she weighs about a
thousand pounds that's a physical
impossibility and stay focused want a
mission here sorry aah
so this is where Hugo stole all their
material from you know what I'll allow
it it's better than this
Hugo had a mechanical man as opposed to
a monkey same thing was gonna happen
with terminator but they fixed that hole
oh but Kyle and his brother Brian what
to cause trouble because the script
really wants that
okay I'm sorry I know it's early in the
review but I gotta give a short little
comedy lesson here water is not fun it's
not it can be funny if it's used to
inflict pain that's funny or may be used
to calm somebody down I'm glad that's
funny but if it's just used to get
somebody wet what are you left with
somebody who's fucking wet look look
Oh embarrassing this will eventually dry
off at some point there's no physical
reproductions for any of this yes
seriously people physical comedy is the
best way to go and insert suppressing
casting choice in three two what
Oh Jason Oh Jason come on who'd you kill
what crime did you commit to have to be
subjected to this punishment you
couldn't have read the script while
doing Seinfeld and actually said to
yourself hey this has potential it has
to be to make you suffer for something
come on you can tell me it's it's
because Jerry knew you were funnier than
him right this was his way of putting
you in your place he's in charge of
running the hotel and making sure
everything goes according to plan and
let me guess
he's the boys's and the mother is and a
great big fancy party is happening and
the odds of any plot device being
original in this movie is
could you just fax me the disappointment
I'm going to receive we then see the
arrival of Dunston in a box with no
holes in it that's promising who belongs
to a performance devoid of any caring by
Rupert Everett that's better you know I
can do all sorts of tricks do you know
what my speciality is hmm yeah I can
make nosy little boys disappear
look I know you're trying to out bad
your doctor claw performance but trust
me nobody's gonna steal the thunder from
that so if there's anyone they can
overact you it's you sad and speaking of
not giving a shit about performance Faye
Dunaway is in this movie too playing the
owner of the hotel is it any coincidence
that the movie she did before this was
called drunks maybe that's why she said
yes to the stinger the Limone people
have decided to award a sixth star do
the most elite hotels in the world yeah
that's right they might be running the
first six star hotel kind of defeats the
purpose a five-star rating but whatever
that would apparently mean that he has
to cancel his vacation with his kids for
a third time Robert I it's an
inconvenience yes when we get the sixth
star you are in for a big bonus and you
can take them someplace fabulous but if
we don't get the six star time off just
won't be a problem will it she's gonna
fire someone for not taking three
vacations
isn't it like having a waiter pay you
for the meal he just brought that's good
to work so it turns out Dunston is being
used by Everett to steal a woman's
jewels on the next floor
oh you will believe that a monkey can be
horribly beaten by his trainer to cry so
he goes in to steal the jewels while
going through an experimental phase that
goes on away Don stick not on your hair
oh I never so after he gets the jewels
he hears Kyle on the roof and goes to
check it out whoa this way we got dark
in a millisecond oh my god this is mean
this movie actually has a good sense if
you go holy lives we substituted pain or
even better death for just a damn messy
joking yeah tercet movie you gave me
hope that an animal could die in this
film but Dunston decides to go rogue and
keeps the jewels for himself that's the
cock account Dunston I've got some
lovely bananas here do quit your hairy
botany that's done you know I have to
admit for us over the top as he is he's
still more subtle than the Duke from
Moulin Rouge I don't know if that's
something to be proud of as most people
share that distinction but is still
worth noting so Kyle tells his dad about
seeing Dunston but his dad doesn't
believe it so he sets up a video camera
to try to film some paranormal activity
I'll go slew my god
they're not you've done every single
monkey cliche in the book you're not
honestly going to do yet they're doing
the monkey in the bed routine where the
person mistakes some sort of strange
animal for a human being in their bed
people I'm not kidding this joke has
been around since the dawn of time no
really I'm not joking he was there at
the birth of man look
man
monkey of course eventually leaves but
comes across Kyle on top of a laundry
chute
thank God they phone an absolute
straight line with no movement or weight
distribution getting in the way or else
they break their necks instantly huh
whoa I'm sorry that sloppy screenwriting
for I sense an immediate connection with
you I think it also translates out to
remember that scene we did a moment ago
with a person not realizing that you're
behind him
remember how unfunny that was you want
to do it again let's do it again come in
oh that's chest-high
I can't oh you are a standing I don't
know what you're doing but it's fabulous
someone's kissing me it must be a
beautiful woman now I'll make sweet love
to you while keeping my eyes closed the
whole time more and more but this time
the father sees Dunston and I have to
admit this is a pretty fun easy I'll
confess that gives a little bit of a
chuckle ah but good God is there
anything remotely funny remotely
humorous that can be brought in to
breathe some life into this movie paging
mr. Herman
mr. Herman you have a crappy movie to
save with a monkey in it
yes ladies and gentlemen we have peewee
or Paul Reubens to be more precise yeah
I know he's in Dunston checks in because
his ding-a-ling checked out but who
cares he's one of the only people to put
any energy in this flag you think it
might be cute to put a baby orangutan in
your kids basket well at first it is
cute then it gets bigger the kids lose
interest and then one night you flush it
down the toilet okay so he's not funny
funny but he tries to kill the monkey
and that gets brownie points in my phone
but Dunston gets away it works its way
to holy crap one really hey maybe chill
monkey Prince isn't off the menu well
God's sake it's just a cut on his hand
what a kill that's mommy if you just
kill this movie got it okay guys so they
fix it that Dunston gets one of the
rooms as we partake in yet another
implausible favorite of the kids are too
stupid a question in file the half-ass
disguise
let's go dr. Manoj okay so man with
glasses fools turtle with hat fools up
chipping chair boys hit do you think
there's a way and we can keep your boys
locked in their rooms you know just till
the crystal ball is over it mrs. Dubrow
I can assure you that there will be no
further incidents yeah we know cause at
this moment they are both car testing
cart hey you don't want them really
funny uh if you did something funny
we're Pradera finds them in the room and
does what most people wanted to do since
the first Santa Claus moving and even
endangered spirit all right just one
more for the nose and now consider this
a happy ending so now we're feeding
repentant go on and give daddy a big hug
ah oh no he opened his mouth and they
added a biting sound effect the good
thing that doesn't leave any marks
whatsoever so he gets the kid loose and
they go downstairs to the ballroom where
they fill the father in on what happened
he tied you up yes and he's gonna hurt
doesn't if he finds him okay
you guys you split up you find the
monkey and you take him upstairs to the
apartment I'm gonna take care of thought
predilection ah let's try this again
he tied you up yes and he's gonna hurt
doesn't if he finds him I'm calling the
police but no then we couldn't get all
sorts of vile arity with people mostly
just getting messy again come on people
big lads come from big pain throw in
some physical humor oh well actually I
guess we do get this back again why is
everyone in this hotel our way Friday
night can we just make the rest of the
movie be we slapping Otho in fact he'll
this could be a stress PSA this is crap
he's not entirely wrong you brought that
muck into my hotel daddy started for me
here
well someone just destroy the cake
already we know it's coming we know it's
not gonna be funny so can we just get it
out of the way here
ah finally cake isn't funny either
unless it's done with Eddie Izzard
report but those are rare very bizarre
exceptions so ever it is arrested Dustin
makes the little yes motion fucking hate
you Alexander gives a look like his
career is over and Dunaway fires him
from his job only to get a job from her
husband I want you to stay this is a
finest hotel in the entire chain what
they didn't like each other they split
up
that's his weekend ho I don't know but
it results in him getting another hotel
job in Bali why because I think the
filming crew really wanted a vacation in
Bali as you can see my family and I are
dedicated to making your stay here at
the Bali majestic is uneventful and
trouble-free as is humanly possible I
can guarantee you with every fiber of my
body there will be no further incidents
we have to deal with on history than
addition native chef is a bit okay no
blood but we do get something truly
worth a rap song I was thought sailing
now watch yeah yo monkey in the ho I
would expect this movie to do anything
different that wasn't Danny ain't
different this movie hits every boring
note every boring cliche every boring
character I guess this is gonna sound
strange but for such a boring tired
premise I'm really shocked it was is
boring and tired it never takes any risk
never does anything different I'm just
waiting any minute for Clint Eastwood
and Clyde to break in and catch our
boring asses so class what if we learn
today monkeys aren't funny they never
have been funny they never will be funny
unless they're being used to cheer up a
fictional dead girl friend was molested
as a child in which case they're
hilarious masters the best pals follow
me touch me there girl
I'm gonna stash
Roberto you don't have to go home I'm
going to hell all about that funk I'm
about to stop tailing now why all your
rig is in all your body is everybody's
and the funky blowout you know we're set
cellphone just around the corner from
the Portobello Road
you think it might be cute but a baby
orangutan and your kids basket